eagle-eye wanna lose control oh I'm
ready to roll and I've been dreaming
about
[Music]
feels like I've been walking in the sky
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do you have a good time up to the sky we
got a sparkle I'm counting down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
feels like good morning Millennials it
feels like a Monday because we took
yesterday off but it is in fact a
Thursday which we appear at the morning
to us to create to be one of the better
days of the week so what is just great
feeling for us it is that I'm not gonna
lie like this week has really thrown me
through Lou I cannot pronounce that
[ __ ] phrase correctly and yesterday
was just so disorientated orienting like
fastest orientating know disorienting I
really feel like I was onto something
there but disorientating I mean go for
it but I know that's not the word um
the fast was so slow oh my god I forgot
it by the way like I had the best night
of my life last night oh my god by the
way we missed you because you were with
Zach's family for the break fast and in
a change of tradition I hosted the break
fest at my house and I just have to say
like ask anyone like I did an amazing
job like I'm sure you did I heard there
were two Carmel cakes there were two
Carvel cakes in Entenmann's crumb cake a
babka there was a Ben Ben's dad brought
whoopie pies that he made from scratch
like I had so much dessert and extra
bagels that I actually like fed the
entire building staff I like left in the
lobby I'm like I could not leave while
that's good at my house like I've died
of diabetes so what did you eat so it
was still funny like everyone came over
around 7:00 and the fast ended I think
it like seven oh six and we were all
just like staring at the cable box until
it turned to 706 like preparing our
bagels at like seven oh four yeah um and
I broke it on a fresca and it was so
good like you know regularly when you're
thirsty and you drink like you feel it
in your belly yeah but I hadn't drank
water or any liquids for 26 hours so I
felt this ice-cold fresca much I'd
chilled in my fridge for a day because I
got them yes I got them two days ago and
it just went so
move Lee down my esophagus like it was
perfection yeah that's the best feeling
and then I had two bagels I only had one
I actually didn't eat as much as I
usually do because I just didn't want to
be in pain I was getting full so I
stopped like I only had one bagel and
then I had like a couple munchkins oh my
god I love much you were such good
master munch and say we're like
artisanal like one was a pumpkin muffin
munchkin which was so good I had two of
those and then a chocolate mom munchkin
and I would cut so full and I was
literally full until I fell asleep and I
was like in pain but I didn't eat this
much usually I eat like baseline two
bagels
I got mature I have my bagel with lox
and then I have like a dessert bagel
that's like cinnamon raisin yeah better
well I was really focused like as a host
I was really focused on the dessert like
I wanted to get the dessert out because
once the dessert was out like that we
could send chill for however long I'm
like I was really proud of the dessert
because I went grocery shopping and I
was so [ __ ] hungry that I just bought
everything inside about Entenmann's
cookies like the best chocolate chip
cookie oh my god I would have eaten so
much at your house and honestly like for
that reason I'm glad that I didn't go
ice cream Carvel cake the whoopie pies
the chocolate chip cookies the Madeline
cookies from Entenmann's like I just
really like puts and then everyone also
brought like mom brought a pecan pie
Ben's dad brought whoopie pies like
everyone was bringing just dessert like
I name is the one thing exactly Olivia
brought to Carvel cakes like it was the
one thing that I had a lot of but
honestly like I'm not upset about the
the ice cream cake sitting in my freezer
right now I know I know you're probably
wanting to wrap this show up so you can
get home to it I have an eyebrow
appointment first but yes very nice
everybody look good though well we're
gonna elect I have my eyebrow
appointment tomorrow like you can't like
I walk around these in this city like
with hairy legs hairy armpits hairy
eyebrows because like any orchid no
one's looking at you I know but like in
LA it's just the bar is higher I know I
know I'm also gonna make an appointment
at doctor Kesey before I lie because
like I can't go with this wrinkle
between my forehead
oh and like maybe a little lip you
didn't accompany me on my last I know it
was so silly of me but now like my
crow's feet like I'm with me my I can't
start doing it on my crow's feet because
then I have nowhere to go and I'm only
26 not turned 27 for less than a month
oh my god okay I know what nothing left
to do if I start doing it all now so
you're wearing your cardigan and I'm
sitting to your side and I could see in
between your buttons I see your boobs oh
my god what a fun day for you
I love hood cardigan right now mm-hmm oh
my god wait but what movie am i quoting
you guys I was thinking cardigans oh I
don't know never been kits when she's
like on the home with her editors
shopping with the cool girls yeah they
find her I love reading tickets I really
was thinking cardigans guys guy
cardigans
also can we just talk a little bit but
how are you feeling last night after the
after the whole day like so we have such
a pit about the impending Yom Kippur
festivities because it's such a hard day
one in which you need to face your sins
like really it's a long hard day it's
the fast started earlier than it usually
does I feel and it was just I think
actually intermittent fasting prepared
me really well because I didn't start to
like feel like death until like 2
o'clock okay I'm actually talking like
more about the emotional part of it no
and then the emotional part of it you
know what I really I mean I repented I
thought about like what I want to do
differently this year
um but it really made me realize like
not being on my phone I thought I was
gonna be so anxious usually usually I
want to be on my phone more than I'm
hungry I can't live without it and like
not being on my phone was such a
pleasure I agree I did not miss it one
bit I do not lean for it one bit and
like I thought I was gonna be anxious
not being able to check what's going on
what people are like writing in our
Facebook group whatever but I had no
anxiety like my phone is my source of my
anxiety and I need to find I know it's
my job but like I need to find a way to
be off it more in like a BMI computer on
my email more like I just need to not be
holding that phone jack I'm getting my
wrist has started to hurt I'm getting
carpal tunnel like I'm on my phone too
much like I care too much about what's
going on in there and being off of it
for 28 hours made me realize I don't
need to be on it all the time Jackie I
couldn't agree more like literally the
fast enter at 7:00 like everyone in my
house was on their phones excuse me I
didn't check my phone till like 9 10
o'clock I so didn't care and normally I
think I would have anxiety about missing
out but something about it being a
holiday and like most of the people that
like are on my team and that just like
worked with me are Jewish that like I
knew no nothing really
the only anxiety I really haven't like
missing work stuff like I don't care
about like missing an Instagram post so
I always having side I think gotta check
my phone I got my email like what's
going on am I making any money today
yeah
and knowing that like everyone else was
off made me feel a lot better about it
and I didn't realize how relaxed and
like cool about it I was until I got
into bed I was like oh my god like I
don't even miss my phone at all no it
was just like this hunk of junk sitting
at the bottom of my purse you know I'm
sitting in my makeup drawer and I'm like
you just you devil you devil
totally also I realized the only people
that I talk to on like a
moment-to-moment basis or are the scenes
and moms so I and none of us were using
our phones so even when I turn my phone
on like I had a couple texts from my
friends like talking about how they were
so hungry but other than that like I had
emails and we had like there's some
stuff in my email to get to today but
nothing was so pertinent to the
situation that like it was crazy I
wasn't on my phone and so some people
like who sent me an email on Tuesday
that I didn't answer like followed up
yesterday there is a special place in
out for people who follow up to emails
like a fighting the answer it's because
I didn't want to you can follow up in a
week no no sooner [ __ ] follow up is it
wholly honest
you didn't answer someone's email and
they need an answer no but I answer my
emails when they need to be answered so
if this didn't get answered you need one
well the email that was followed up on
was something I've sent to both of us
and we do need to answer them we just
don't have the answer what was it's
something with them looked at so yeah oh
yeah yeah well I've ever say ignore this
right they do need to be answered via
whatever um I was just like feeling
after dinner last night like I was so
full I had had like a piece of like
three pieces of ice cream cake two full
bagels like and I was dancing around my
apartment feeling so light and I think
it's because I absolved all these sins
and like I've really been forgiven and I
really just like I was reading the
English portion because I did the whole
prayers in Hebrew and then I was like I
don't even know I'm saying like yeah
when you have to like say all the sins
some of these are familiar but whatever
you know but it's like what's the point
in in apologizing in a different
language if you don't know what you're
saying yes and I sat down just cuz I
wanted to sit if you were hurting me and
I was started reading some of the
English sins and it's like I really
thought when I walked in to show that to
him like I want to see a great person
like I don't have much to apologize for
it but turns out I do because there was
so many sins in that book that really
spoke to me like baseless hatred he's
like me like I hate so many people and
things like for absolutely no reason
that's like a terrible way to live
yeah I didn't realize that was like a
bad thing I thought it made me funny you
know ya know it's very specific and
they're considering it was written
thousands of years ago right and then
there was obviously Envy
gossip was a so'ming gossip is a term I
know but you know I have a problem with
gossip being considered a sin because to
me some sharing exchange of information
is something that goes from information
sharing to gossip may you know that line
yeah yeah it's not just like oh like
Sally got a new card right Sally got a
new car like because she crush the old
one with the DUI right or like how does
she wear that right she doesn't have a
job yeah I guess I chose a line I just
like for me like that's not the one I
really harp down because I know I'm not
gonna stop talking [ __ ] it's literally
my job and it's honestly one that brings
me great joy like I think we share we do
we just this is this platform is a extra
exchange of information platform yes
it's a them exchange of knowledge and I
feel like we don't necessarily talk [ __ ]
unless it's absolutely necessary right
and you know what Jana Kramer
I thought we handled it well like I feel
actually had a pet about the Jenna
Kramer thing because I thought maybe
like someone would be like the morning
shows girls were talking about you 28
minutes and 30 seconds yes they did and
she heard it for sure and surely thought
about that and I feel as though it was a
balanced argument like right like you
felt the need to like speak on it but I
didn't so much so I'm able to give her
what she wants to hear more right you
know what I mean yeah no I have to say
unless it's the other way where like I'm
so heated about something and then you
know you play devil's advocate so it's
like whoever we're talking about hears
both sides and they're right I try and
now like to speak on most issues on the
toast like with the underlying
understanding and that the person we're
talking about might actually hear it
yeah but you know what that sometimes a
good opportunity to tell them to stop
posting cheesy instagrams
agreed agreed so anyways it was a great
day we are now like as far away from Yom
Kippur as the Lockerbie we were sitting
at the meal last night at Margo goes 365
more days Wow snacks are it's like the
best feeling ever it's the worst when
it's your birthday and it's like 365
more days until your birth no but the
feeling of being so far away from yom
kippur like of next year is one in which
you can't pay for like it's the best
most like amazing feeling yeah and i
hope everyone had an easy fast got to
spend some time with the family reflect
absolve yeah i hope everything
brighter and lighter brighter lighter um
and i definitely am feeling brighter and
lighter and that's a perfect way you
want to feel when you're diving into
weird
into the past five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast actually
no one needs to know these stories more
than us because I'm so out of touch of
what's been going on because I was not
on my phone so it's time but it's also
Thursday which means that today's
episode is brought to you by Thursday
boots Jack and I are both wearing our
Thursday beauties in the eye I believe
we're wearing the same style but just in
a different color slash pattern yours or
cherry and mine are black patent-leather
I feel like these two shoes are really
like in representative of our
personalities like Harry White happy
spring for you and like dark black
leather don't talk to me anyway just
want to say about these Thursday boots
that I wore last week um I wore them all
day like literally from the show until
we went to dinner on Olivia's like all
[ __ ] day and my my feet felt great
I'm so happy like well better than they
did if I were wearing flats honestly
like these do great things for the Soul
well today is Thursday and it's
officially boot season just in time for
the start of fall we received a few of
the new releases from our friends at
Thursday boots Thursday boots is an NYC
based startup brand that designs really
really comfortable high-quality boots
and sells them at a very accessible
direct-to-consumer price they make
handcrafted boots in the same North
American and European European
facilities as brands that charge two to
four times the price but their sake you
can use the higher quality materials and
still sell them at a lower price because
they don't have to deal with the retail
markups and wholesalers and we're classy
over here vogue actually ranked them
among the best fall boots for under $200
and they rarely rarely highlight startup
brands you deserve more comfortable
boots without the high retail markups if
you want a fast fashion or shoes that
rarely make it out of your closet don't
shop at Thursday boots Thursday boots is
an investment in comfort timeless styles
and staples that will last for years
Thursday boots believes in year-round
honest prices so while they jump to
discounts or sales they're giving our
listeners a - a free two-day shipping on
their first order and they always offer
free returns and exchanges which is the
only way to shop online I can't deal
with companies that don't do that um so
you have nothing to lose trying out a
few pairs go to Thursday boots calm /
toast
and you can have a pair on your doorstep
before next Thursday that's th urs da y
Bo OTS dot-com / toast for free two day
shipping
returns and exchanges sign on and look
fly sign on and look fly also someone
asks where's Margo great question oh
right the snitches
SiC yes she was watching her stories
you've watched her degenerate a place
where she can no longer come to work she
fled my house last night like the second
dessert was wrapped up but didn't even
offer to help clean up which was so
incredibly rude but because she's sick
and honestly think she should take
tomorrow off too because we have we
leave for LA on Saturday my show was
Sunday tickets available Karl no job
calm and we're spending the entire week
in LA and then me and my girls are going
to San Diego San Francisco for my show
tickets available Carla no job calm and
I just think like if she doesn't get
better like it'll be a very difficult
week for her it will but even if she
doesn't get better and she goes to LA I
think the LA sunshine like by this
Veterans Day by the time she leaves LA
she'll be okay
but I agree smashed if you're watching
this but you're not um you don't have to
come to work tomorrow yeah the snacks
are speaking a myth snatcher I wish she
was here for this first story because
she is our resident expert who's arts
natural correspondent she's this natural
correspondent to the snatches but new
bachelor Peter Weber gets stitches after
splitting his face open ahead of filming
I thought it was during filming new
bachelor Peter let work during filming -
yeah let's get in I think it is maybe I
just don't know what a head means new
bachelor Peter Webber's on the mend
after undergoing emergency surgery in
Costa Rica people confirms during the
game of golf on Monday the ABC leading
man split his head open after he fell
hit his head on multiple cocktail
glasses radar Online reports quote he
went to step on the cart but fell and
split his face open on to cocktail
glasses he was carrying as a result of
the nasty injury Weber reportedly
traveled two hours to a hospital for an
operation in which she received 22
stitches in his face he is pulling
through a source told radar Online okay
um maybe he's not filming he was playing
golf he's a hundred percent filming it
sucked to open by the way the confusing
but I've been seeing on reality a hosted
like there was a date like and some
toasters got to go as like extras at the
concert yeah he's filming
perhaps though his day off and he was
golfing yeah which would actually make
things worse cuz they like then they
didn't get the foot and bein seen on
camera and they couldn't tease it all
season they loved an ambulance moment
they love an ambulance moment they'll
just like call it just did I get that we
like remembering Carly wild like called
the ambulance on herself in Mexico for
like no reason yeah and they just think
wanted to sit in the AC yeah and like
talk about their feelings gamers love
anyone
when Kelsey Poe called the ambulance and
she was just like taking an insight
attack I don't think you remember Kelsey
Poe but no he gave us such a gift
her husband Sanderson Poe yo you have to
watch
it's from crystallises season she was
civilian villain case by Lance Ito yeah
and she like went nowhere after so I'm
even know what her intentions were but
she had an ex-husband I think she was a
widow and his name was Sanderson mm-hmm
just the way she was behaving and
talking about Sanderson like by the end
you just like assume that she murdered
him right it was crazy
um speaking of crazy I know it's
probably not a story but are you seeing
all this drama in the UK with like the
football wives not even oh my god it was
going so viral on Twitter like it means
nothing to me because I don't know who
these two soccer stars are football yeah
soccer but apparently like one of them
out in the other on Instagram the other
day being like I've had stories being
sold to the Sun which I guess is like a
tabloid there for months about me and I
had a sneaking suspicion who it was
because only very few people follow my
private Instagram and a lot of the
stories were coming from there so I
started to put up a bunch of Instagram
stories and block to everyone from
seeing and except this one person and
seeing if they would make it to the Sun
and of course they did and then at the
end of her long statement she goes
it's dot dot dot Wayne I forget her name
she said the girl's name and like it
blew up like people were talking about
it ever her name is carlo rooney and i
forgot the name of the girl that Coleen
Rooney sorry and then forgot the name of
the girl that she is accusing of selling
the stories then that girl released the
statement but it's like the biggest
drama in the UK right now like
everywhere female soccer players wives
it's the wives of male soccer players I
believe that's crazy
yeah good for her I love a little
sleuthing she should join the TIAA yeah
it was so it was so funny her statement
was like so long at the end then she
goes
it's dot dot I don't think she was gonna
say who it was I know it's just like a
statement about her feelings you know
yeah new book that to release it
I'd say the name hey that's like go
viral saying the name sit yeah no I hate
when people like speak in tongues like
give him a hundred percent I find it
really annoying also did you see um
empty and John Doe we're like tweeting
up a storm last night because I didn't
see Dan Schneider is in the process he's
deleted in the last 24 hours like
thirteen thousand tweets these are
coming back to Twitter and like deleting
all the sweets makes you think yeah I'll
just be over here waiting for my news
notification people who say delete
delete their tweets like
are so confusing to me it's not
confusing like you're hiding something
yeah you know who does that
100 yeah um anyways Peter Webber so its
face open so that it's definitely gonna
throw a wrench in the bachelor plans but
I think it'll just act like it seems
like he's okay and he's recovering so
now there was just gonna find a way to
exploit it and make for good television
yeah I wonder I'm like who's gonna be by
his side you know like yeah oh man I was
so worried about you put things into
perspective right no by that's what it's
gonna be like it's like you like some
girls gonna be like talking about
confessionals like this is like so great
like you really realize like how short
life is ya know he's gonna say that yeah
he's gonna say like I saw you know the
cocktail glass flashed before my eyes
now also we need to talk about the
circumstances of this you know incident
like was he drunk he was holding two
cocktails golfing I don't know people
drink what they go yeah but I don't
think he's like drunk like blacked out I
think he was just like tipsy missed the
golf cart stuff I don't think it's like
he has a drinking problem but he
probably was just drinking on the day
off like honestly the bachelor seems
like a lot of work yeah he was probably
golfing with Chris Harrison drinking
mimosas
yeah and Chris Harrison posted an update
to his to his Instagram which they used
as like the official bachelor like
message board and it was like peers I'm
I'm glad to hear Peter sign and that's
just really crazy and then it makes you
think like I can't believe this hasn't
happened in previous seasons yeah got
injured on the job but it's not even on
the job he was having to take off
playing golf that we just assumed that I
think that's a fair assumption I think
that's a fair assumption to unless they
had a golf date which sounds like
torture oh my god I which I torture kill
me like not only is golf like not that
fun but like it's so long and also it's
very hot like you just stand in the Sun
all day like I've just been as play golf
like since I met him probably six
hundred times and I've never gone once
of course he said come drive the car I'm
like I'd literally rather stay in bed
with you ten times of course yeah of
course um anyways thinking of Peter hope
the Scotch heals hope the thought chills
the Fox is a terrible place too and you
know in turn an injury because it's red
in the face right if boxers on the patch
the thatch is on the fact okay next
story something that went down yes while
we were off line that is just sweeping
the nation
Matt Lauer is denying quote false and
salacious rape
Jen says affair was quote consensual I
heard this yesterday I was like out of
touch and I heard someone I may be my
building they were like listening to a
radio and I was like waiting for the
mail and it said Matt Lauer accused of
rape and I was like not again I know and
what's crazy is a few date like on
Monday when I was looking for stories
one of the stories was Matt Lauer pops
up on his daughters tick-tock
I think he was like trying crying it's
like whack-a-mole he's trying to come
back up and robear I was like boom not
today nope so he was like being cute and
like being dad like on tick tock but he
apparently allegedly he's a rapist I
also sold Reese Witherspoon like doing
something like mom on tick tock and I
like wanted to roll my eyes but the
video was actually pretty funny yeah I
thought it was like teaching I never
take the time to watch the videos I
thought it was funny actually I give it
a two thumbs up I endorse it I think I
like when people like kosair take talks
to Instagram like and I get that's how
I'll consume it
other than that I'm out yeah I'm gonna
be 27 student I have no business on so I
actually downloaded to talk the other
day and I didn't realize I mean I I knew
but they keep your musically account so
I logged in with my facebook or whatever
and it was my girl within the job
account when I tried to make him
musically and it was mortifying like I
literally was sitting there with Mario
deleting every single thing I posted
because I wanted to die of shame that's
hilarious have it for lurking look I
think it's funny I wanna see what the
kids are up to do you think in a
different time like I would have been a
tick-tock star because I love to lip
sync and dance like maybe wouldn't be
too musically start cuz that's not what
tick tock is anymore
no but it is no yes it is it's like
dancing and and lip syncing and remix
saying and no I'm telling you look I was
it's like now it's like funny like 9
it's fine but like a little bit longer
and vertical vertical well I think
there's like different Jonas for sure
but it's not really like what musically
was oh well I mean that's good because
tick tock is huge but I think it's also
just the name like people have to say it
yeah and you know what it makes me think
tick tock on the clock but the party
don't stop
tick tock on ABBA imma blow two speakers
up tonight I think that's that's good um
anyways back to Matt Lauer he penned a
letter on Wednesday morning staunchly
denying former NBC News co-worker Brooke
nevels is
allegations that he raped her in his
hotel room at the 2014 Sochi Olympics no
Lauer says so she wasn't hard enough
right like that's the thing you just
hear more and more like about how
terrible things Matt's are details and
it's looking like Sochi was a huge
mistake
totally Lauer says the accusation as
detailed in Ronan Pharaoh's new book
catch and kill his quote categorically
false ignores the facts and defies
common sense calling me encounter with
nevels a quote extramarital affair I
don't know if Rona foul wrote it I
believe he dismisses the claims as part
of a promotional effort to sell a book
in the book obtained by variety Neville
said Lauer anally raped her one night in
Sochi Russia Lauer calls the act
consensual we performed oral sex on each
other we had vaginal sex and we had anal
sex each act was mutual and completely
consensual he writes Lauer claims the
encounter marked the beginning of an
affair that continued when they returned
to New York oh my god like you know Matt
Lauer's so nasty looking like the
thought of him having anal like I could
actually vomit and I know this is just
another he-said she-said but like I'm
standing firmly on Ronan Farrow side
like I think find him to be a really
honest journalist and I'm trying to
publish something that's why just like
Matt Lauer's credibility is just out the
way ever since I heard about that button
right I knew he was a sick [ __ ] and
nothing that comes out of his mouth it
is credible tonight right
you know I told you I started watching
the affair yeah as he recommended it I
just finished season one last night and
did you like it you weren't loving it I
wasn't loving it but now that the way
season 1 ended like I'll definitely
watch season 2 and you said it gets
better but and this just reminds me of
that one because it's an affair and to
because it's so much about like the way
people see things Oh totally like I mean
this is way more like extreme but even
in the fair like she remembers herself
wearing one thing he remembers her
wearing another thing or like saying
something or see you remember see it
doesn't go like that forever but the I'm
tired of what's really annoying twice
but the first or maybe the first two
seasons of the affair is a 60-minute
episode and the first 30 minutes are
what happens at the restaurant from one
person's perspective and then the second
30 minutes are what happens at the
restaurant from the other person's
perspective so you're watching the same
incident but how people remember it and
it's like it would be interesting like
for one episode it really gets annoying
but I agree it's like percept not that
I'm chalking this up to percent because
I'm 100% sure that he raped her but as a
separate conversation
actually totally agree that like two
people can be telling the truth oh
that's like when we were talking about
we we were both watching that um that
radio drama with Heather McDonald you
remember yeah someone one toaster
flagged it for us like there was this
drama where this girl was opening for
Heather McDonald in Atlanta Atlanta
whatever I don't go into it and I was
watching this girl go on the radio and
like slam had the Ratana and then I was
listening to her Madonna's podcast of
her like saying what happened and I got
the vibe but they were both telling the
truth yeah they both are remember like
they saw right so I don't think either
one of them is lying that's like a lot
of the problem with like housewives it's
like they're talking about the incident
and no one's lying but they are
definitely just preceding it differently
yeah no but it was interesting it's like
he remembers her rang like this short
waitress dress and like her dress that
she was like the lower one is like below
her knee and her hair is back but he
remembers her with like Vava who like
that thing was interesting but then
there were some like things that happen
where it's like wait how did you not
remember who pulled the gun first yeah
like that where it matters right where
it matters yeah so um yeah um I'll stick
with it but it's so far it's really not
my kind of show that's why they say
there's three sides to every story right
yours line and the truth yeah even
though mine is like most likely the
truth sure um anyways for this girl for
speaking out yet another nail and Matt
Lauer's coffin and I truly hope he never
works again I know but he I think
there's something in him I mean I don't
know if anymore well yes because he
released a statement saying it's not
true but like he thinks he's coming back
where I feel like every six months I
read an article he said gearing up to
come back into the city like yeah he's
like on Long Island like with his family
yeah but he's like trying to cross the
bridge and every time it's like the
bridge trolls are coming up were you the
one who told me that Billy Bush was back
on something yes yes job doing like one
of those correspondents yeah Matt Lauer
really reminds me of Billy Bush even
though they did two totally different
things no no when you but it's like
really - it's like of course Billy but
should come back and not Larry what do
you think of the Jill said some stuff
and was part of saying things that were
not good at all but like Matt Lauer's I
mean clues of raping people right it's
not the same they should punish make
shouldn't be the same right like a milli
bunch like if I were really Bush I think
I'm like why am i in this boat right no
cuz he's out like I totally loop him and
Matt Lauer together 100% even though and
this is what we've always said there's
in cancel culture there's a huge
difference between doing something wrong
and saying something right because you
can learn and like everyone says dumb
[ __ ] whatever but like there's a huge
difference and I feel like these days
people like loop in canceled culture of
like of like a Matt Lauer and like a
Kevin Hart Kevin I just said something
stupid like he's not a murderer no a
rapist and the more thing about canceled
culture like this is how I define it and
this is how I decide who needs to be
cancelled if you could be arrested for
what you did cancelled oh agree if you
couldn't not cancelled okay well so
that's a fair bar everyone has a
different judgment but that's where I'm
going with it I would like to share an
insight I found my true village meals
Instagram page because it really spoke
to me at about our experience with
cancel coulter feed about what she said
on Trevor Noah
yes assassination I loved her on Trevor
Noah she says you're safe in my social
sphere to admit you don't know the
answers as long as you're willing and
eager to find them there's no shame in
ignorance that is being addressed and
replaced with education and knowledge so
basically what she was saying on what
sideshow Trevor Noah Trevor Noah which
I've literally never watched before in
my life have you it was my first time
ever what she said was like canceled
cultures to a problematic because it
doesn't leave any room for growth right
like ten years ago we were all different
people the culture was different so
crazy I was just watching Entourage and
they said the word the R word 1,000
times in one episode I'm like you would
never be able and it's just like a few
there was a song on the radio come let's
get our word in here yeah that's what to
me is like that crux so it's very
critical for like the culture to assume
like once you say something stupid 10
years ago like you're dead in water
right because as a culture we should be
done in the water because we let us song
go on the radio that said let's get our
right no it's crazy and by the way
everyone in my high school used to say
that word and it wasn't even considered
a bad word no it was you can't use like
today's standards to judge what people
did right 10 years ago that's one by the
way that's one thing of what people did
years ago next unless it's unless you've
read someone years ago it's still down
right there's a huge difference I just
hate that like the culture of like
canceled culture I started to loop in
people who do bad things and people who
say who said bad things yeah you know a
hundred percent and that's with the
Billy Bush and uh
Matt Lauer if at all because in no way
am i condoning what Billy Bush said in
2000 whatever it was horrible but let's
not compare him to you know I am the one
comparing him let's not go to him -
Mallory break someone and watch girls in
his office we're the ones who built this
boat no but because let that is what
people associate yeah yeah yeah totally
also I really don't think that I could
even you know address the affair without
singing the theme song I'm sorry go for
you like this theme I feel because I
remember you and Margo singing it Oh
scream in or do the game yet at the
moment of my death did my last breath
I've always it made an avalanche of
Barry Madden about you when he died his
widowed bride met your daddy and they
made you ha have only one thing to do
and that's be the way that I am and then
sinks back into the ocean I have only
one thing to do and that's be the way
that I am and then sink back into the
ocean
sink back in Judeo sink back into the
ocean sink back into the OC second video
we should sink back into the ocean such
a good theme song it is it's one of the
few ones that I don't skip I think it's
so good skip it yes sure times a little
annoying yeah but it's so now I'm
becoming familiar with it it is
interesting it's a great song
interesting like when you listen to a
song and nothing is conjunction with a
show because I was thinking that could
also mean a theme song for big little
lies yeah it's similar vibe it's also
just like a regular song on Spotify
Britain might be on Apple right and then
like put over like footage of ocean oh
right yes a little I've also been watch
the politician last night and I was
rewatching with him and I never knew the
theme song but apparently took a really
popular song do you know it what is
Chicago it's called sing it I can
something weird happened on my Spotify
and I'm just wondering if it only
happened to me where I can no longer
listen to I wish I had a river by Ben
Platt it went dark
oh that doesn't happen for me have you
tried in last few days you haven't a
check right now yeah that's a terrible
thing if you don't like your mother
targeted it feels like I'm being
targeted can't have any joy actually
maybe it's sadness it's like a river I
could say and I was watching I caught
over millions and they played that song
River by Joni Mitchell
and maybe your room right went dark that
is so weird it's just a song ska and
everyone so I don't know what that means
for us but it's not looking good I'm
sorry um we took a nice tangent on that
story yeah anyways matt lauer go back
into your home okay
next story Claudia just updating me on
because I had no clue that while we were
asleep this story has taken on a life of
its own because earlier this week Ellen
DeGeneres went on her show talking about
how people were upset that she was
sitting next to George Bush she was
getting a lot of flack at the Dallas
Cowboys game because they cut to her
being like all the celebrities and she
was sitting there with George W Bush
laughing like smiling yeah and they got
she got so much [ __ ] for it and so much
so that she had to address it on her
show yeah and she made like a really
sweat I thought it was like sweet and
cute about her like people who are
different can still be friends and she
says I have a ton of friends who have
different political views than me and I
feel like we've gotten so far past that
point that you can't remember like it's
okay to be friends with people who think
differently differently than you and in
fact it's actually more important to be
friends with people who think
differently because it challenges
challenging you like you challenge each
other and that's just like a fundamental
right and as much as I like Loki hate
Ellen actually really liked a video meet
you actually liked on my Instagram I
just thought it was like a good message
in these trying times yeah in these
trying times we're not trying and never
did I say I didn't even choose it as a
story for the show because I was just
like oh another you know like cute Ellen
moment whatever yeah never did I think
that she was gonna get backlash for this
so much Vanity Fair wrote like a huge
op-ed that a lot of people were getting
involved in the conversation as
including Mark Ruffalo which was like so
random I didn't even know he had a
Twitter until like someone retweeted it
and came up on my Twitter I was like
well he's not Ruffalo I'm a Twitter
totally they wrote an article called
Ellen DeGeneres towards W Bush and the
limits of unconditional kindness it says
that for decades DeGeneres has been the
sunny representative for a brighter
world we might all live in if we were
kinder to one another but that imagined
utopia seems increasingly out of touch
with reality I refuse to believe that
I'm sorry and I refuse to get behind
that sort of thinking because I I have
friends colleagues from all sides of the
political spectrum truly like from
people I grew up with like super
conservative
people I know who are you know fundraise
for Elizabeth Warren like I don't care
and I think that having that sort of
messaging is actually like sad and like
that's what the world has come to you
like I repeat I'm sorry I refuse to to
believe that yeah I refuse to believe
that too I thought what Ellen said was
so obvious I am like really shocked when
you told me that it was a controversial
thing to say and then I think the most
shocking part of this whole thing is
that when Ellen went on her show and
said this like the clip of her saying it
like went viral until it turned to
negative and people were first like you
know applauding her and Reese
Witherspoon retweeted it and you know
should support and then someone pointed
out that every screw this one actually
deleted her tweet like now that there's
all this controversy and I just have to
say like I think that is one of the
lousiest things ever like if you're
gonna say something stand by it - Ellen
is your friends like don't be a coward
and I just thought it was like so losery
like if you're gonna tweet something if
your buddies for this food you know what
you're tweeting is gonna be screenshot
in so you're deleting it now you just
look like a [ __ ] yeah now you look like
you don't know what you stand for right
which is like even worse no worse than
standing for what people my thing is the
wrong core is unpopular unless you have
a stance right at least you can stand
because you have a spine yeah and it all
comes back to the spine yeah yeah this
is really shocking I really liked what
Alan said and that's my right and I
can't tell how difficult it is for me
because like a part of me like really
doesn't like Alan like and a part of me
used to absolutely love her and like
cried when she got that medal from Obama
and like she was crying like I loved it
and I really liked her but just all the
things that I've heard about her like
being the devil makes me not like her um
but then again like you just you have to
pay homage Jake she was the first book
game woman on television whatever like I
just feel like honestly I feel really
conflicted about Ellen cuz like right
all the things I know about her
personally and then all the things like
she puts out there like she seems like
she's always giving people Walmart like
a million dollars you know yeah um she
brought us know our inner true so she
brought us Sophia Grace and Rosie but
then but then she was also extremely
rude to Mason Ramsey that's true
remember that in June we took her in
elympios yeah that's what I was gonna
say yeah but Kareem said she was so rude
yeah and Corrine was like so nervous
like so excited she was like one of the
now batch of people going Ellen all the
time but Krim was like one of the first
and especially who wasn't a lead and
that she just had Ellen was awful like
yeah like you're not allowed to you're
not allowed to run into Ellen in the
Kardashian
love her so much and she went to the
Cowboys game with Corey what yes they
Chris posted a picture was Ellen Portia
and Cory selfie on a private plane they
went to the Cowboys game because Cory's
a big Cowboys fan Oh fun fun so then
it's like oh my gosh if Ellen is hanging
out with Cory and Chris like those are
my people now now I'm turning honestly
part of me just like loads like the
Ellen entity because of her producer ya
know producer um Andy who like she's
always like Andy Andy and I was like all
for the stick until I woke up one
morning and he was tweeting I mean it
was a day got canceled and he really
like cause a huge influx like the story
got so much bigger because he Angie was
coming for me dancing on Your Grave
totally and you know what's so weird is
that he went to her Ma's I know his I
know his niece nephews like he like and
I know his brother his brother was my
hockey coach like it was so weird he's
like he's a bunch of his family went to
her mom's like he was just like a guy
from my high school I'm like he's out
here tweeting at me and like made this
story so much bigger so now I can't
watch that show without a pit for sure
and that's a really crazy thing that you
played hockey I Laura hockey and
honestly it was pretty good I started in
eighth grade and then ever you joined
the team in the eleventh grade and I had
gained so much weight by the 11th grade
like I literally couldn't breathe in the
math what's crazy it's like you think
you had gained so much weight but like
oh and I look at pictures and I'm like
oh my god is the skinniest Beauty ever
85 pounds you know but I really was so
much more out of shape than they live in
grade that I got benched and for me I
only joined teams that I could play on
so like I got benched on the volleyball
and the bass small team and I ended up
quitting it's like what I don't need to
stay after school just said I better to
ride the bed I homework to jail there's
no cell service in the gym no it's so
true it was such [ __ ] like honestly
I I know you should be a team player
like that's what you learn when you're a
kid but like [ __ ] that yeah I'm all that
time management
I'm sitting in the gym and those cell
phone service when I can be writing my
term paper no and it's like there's a
difference between like being a sub and
riding the bench you know like if you're
stuff like you go right you need to
break your two breaths then you go back
in I was out of sub I was just like a
bench ER yeah
yes scrub I agree there's no time for
that like we had homework yeah okay
doctor zone thing I would actually
really love to hear people's thoughts on
AIM
and I've been reading tweets on both
sides and like this is one of those
things like I hear what everyone's
saying but at the end of the day like
why can't me run with the message of
just unity I feel like that's one in
which we really need right now
and I'm I'm taking L inside and it pains
me because I just I don't know why like
I have a thing against Ellen's and today
yeah we just actually makes you taking
her side like more powerful like you're
not biased towards liking her and not
liking her I know and just looking at
the argument for when two days and it
know people don't like George Bush and
they've some say he was like the worst
president history Blake he's so Q I know
it's terrible say it's terrible sorry
I'm sorry okay next up Mindy Kaling is
making news she published an article
that oh I saw this is so crazy I mean
the articles like really long and well
write and then you should read it for
yourself and I'm just gonna read what my
newsletter summed up for me Mindy Kaling
says the television Academy once tried
removing her name from the list of
producers when the office was nominated
for an Emmy injustice the actress tells
Elle magazine that she was told she was
going to be cut because there were too
many producers on the show Kaelin claims
she was the only one who was made to
fill out a form and write an essay about
all of her contributions as a writer and
producer and had to quote get letters
from all the other male white producers
explaining what she contributed that's
awful oh that's awful and that is like
exactly why women like that's your worst
fear as a woman it's like someone's
gonna ask you like what you're
contributing super it's like the
imposter syndrome where you already feel
like an imposter and now you have to
prove that you're right that gives me
like so that makes me so angry
yeah Mindy Kaling then did some
follow-up tweets because I guess the
article was picking up a lot of traction
and she was like honestly I never wanted
to tell this story it was like who wants
to make an enemy out of the Academy like
they literally make careers with their
awards but like honestly it was so weird
I was the only one cut I was the only
woman and I was the only woman of color
so like of course I had to think that I
was the easiest target like no one would
care if I got cut and in fact she's did
you test me cuz like when you think
about how many Kaelin got started like
she was just a person on the office you
know like a million people were on the
office and nobody really has gotten as
big except for Michael Scott whatever
same as uh she's broken Steve Carell yes
I don't know like there were so many was
like huge ensemble show and like she
really got so big and it's probably a do
large a part to her contribution
creatively not just as an actress played
behind the scenes writing producing also
Jim got big did he yeah he's a big movie
star oh that's yeah oh yeah we don't
watch the office it's a show
that I thought is stupid and terrible
John Krasinski yeah but like he also he
played the game like he got a big movie
star but like he also married Emily
Blunt like Mindy Kaling is one person
who got to where she is strictly based
on her merits she didn't marry anyone
famous she'd suck any one thing that's
like she is famous and Tao and
successful because of her talent I think
that's really cool actually like to
stand Mindy Kaling and I thought the
Mindy Kaling show uh deserved more Todd
says totally did you watch her new movie
no night writer late night whatever I'm
saving it for a plane maybe I why the
way I watched it on the plane it was
cute
yeah it's an epic movie no it's just me
yeah I know I thought was Netflix no
it's it was cute
I don't like Stan Emma Thompson I'm not
gonna lie like honestly I did I do think
she did a great part as the teapot and
Beauty and the Beast but other than that
I don't like ride-or-die for her so I
wasn't like dying like Cline let me see
I'm a topic you know what she doesn't
give up emma thompson vibes in this
movie like she really becomes her
character that it was she's like a
reverend it wasn't until after i watch
the movie did i realize it was Emma
Thompson okay so that's like a fun thing
fun yeah yeah um anyways like justice
for Mindy Kaling up down left right and
center ah I don't know I just think my
brain wasn't and I watched the trailer
again for the morning show last night
and I'm really excited when does it come
out November first wow that's so soon
hmm
excited it's really good and like Steve
Carell gives me like Matt Lauer vibes
like oh he's a creepy no like he is
fired I don't know why I got hires it's
a lock under his desk maybe like that
seems to be you know for those who don't
know what we're referring to it came out
and all the Matt Lauer drama that he let
her had a button under his desk that
would close and lock his door it's like
he could be like Oh Sally when you will
you come in here and then she'd come in
then he locked the door yeah like he had
an auto lock button under his that's
weak like you're not working in the CIA
right like nothing you're doing is that
and poor confidential but also like your
morning show what do you have an office
for no you're like an able-bodied young
man get up and lock the door totally
like this is definitely button it was
definitely something that I would have
just cuz I'm like way too lazy they got
up and closed the door like I feel like
I need it for my health but that's true
like Matt Lauer are you an able-bodied
man that you have more stamina like you
should be able to close store they get
the hell up yes I be so [ __ ] lazy
okay
fifth and final story just like an
interesting cultural story smartphone
typists are catching up to keyboard
users we I'm sorry is this is his little
tech news it's
little tech news that's brought to you
by one of our favorite startups none of
you considered a start-up but article
furniture we spoke about them a few
times on the show it's the easiest way
to make your space look beautiful right
now they're all about no fuss
entertaining from lounge about poof's
and sectionals to stackable chairs oh my
god I love that idea
in the event of extra guests article is
here to help you make entertaining
season stress-free and beautiful there's
actually a great point because I have
six chairs my dining room table but I
entertain for 8:00 last night and I
Charlie asked my doorman if he had any
folding chairs and thank God they had
some ones in the basement or else I
would've had to run out to get folding
chairs like weird even for two chairs
the idea of stackable chairs is genius
so any of extra chairs you can throw in
a closet they don't take up that much
space I love that idea
furniture shopping is famously terrible
very true its overeager sales people
poor quality pieces interminable
shipping periods the works
that's my article decided to change the
way people shop for furniture instead of
schlepping to a warehouse to shop for a
particular board articles online
warehouse features high quality pieces
that you can browse right at home
articles team of designers have an eye
on today's trends but focus on timeless
designs and great quality Plus in stock
items ship in two weeks or less oh my
god furniture taking like six to eight
weeks to ship is criminal I ordered like
a cute like shearling like off-white
ottoman from article and it literally
came in like a week and a half it was so
easy like they call me I'm like just
deliberate and they just delivered it
like it was seamless like the way it
should be and it was like super cheap so
that's what I really appreciate it in
the state I've had it for over a year
now and it stayed in really good
condition
even though bed as I was putting it's
[ __ ] dirty shoes on it they keep
their prices low by cutting down and
cutting out the middleman and selling
directly to you know showrooms to sell
pieces people know retail markups their
team of designers focus on beautifully
crafted pieces quality of material and
excellent construction they are
dedicated to a modern aesthetic with
Scandinavian touches all in stock items
are delivered in two weeks or less they
have a 30-day return policy with simple
returns and exchanges and they're
offering our listeners $50 off their
first purchase of $100 or more to claim
visit article dot-com slash toast and
the discount will be automatically
applied at check out that's article
dot-com slash toast to get $50 off your
first purchase for $100 or more article
Tom slash toast
sign on and furnishes a [ __ ] out of your
apartment do it apparently you're
talking faster than ever today oh I'm
sorry you know I actually thought that
for a second and now they're getting a
bunch of comments I'm sorry so let me
give a fair read to the brand
that's article dot-com / toast article
is a great low cost high quality high
quality furniture company they have no
middleman that's how they're able to
give you a good price
again that's article comm / toast when
your first purchase
$50 off if you're spending $100 or more
love to hear it
smartphone typists are catching up to
keyboard users a new study says this is
an interesting study wow that is
interesting when it comes to smartphones
people are all thumbs and that's not a
bad thing according to researchers who
say the speed of smartphone typing is
catching up with the speed of typing on
normal keyboards smartphone users type
only about 25% slower than keyboard
typists and some even reach a speedy 85
words per minute according to a study
from Aalto University and some other
universities
ok like I hear that like I okay like I
get there saying if you're really typing
per minute but something about using all
my fingers on a computer makes me feel
it more accomplished more fast like
something every time I send an email on
my phone I'm like oh this is so janky
this email is not gonna get there
there's something I don't like doing
official things on my phone like I do it
when I have to but if I have business to
take care of like I'm on my computer
there's something about utilizing all my
sums and my index and my ring you tip
your pinky no maybe hit that [ __ ] enter
ya caps lock I just I prefer a keyboard
but I do definitely feel the call that
like we were probably typing on her
phone says just as fast of a rate as we
used to on I think we're getting super
fast I'm actually it's such a fast typer
on a keyboard which I could have been a
speed Piper do you remember those
classes that was those were the best
that an Oregon Trail speaking teaches
typing may this bacon yes and then also
like when you're ox died of sedentary in
Oregon Trail yeah but it's like the
smart kids we're playing me this weekend
totally I used to love that game I want
to tell him what a typing game I know
but he learned that it was to teach you
how to type that's actually so true and
I know that like people of an older
generation like really have a hard time
typing like Ben's parents like yeah you
do have an issue fingers yeah they have
a computer in their house and like they
can not figure out how to print like
anytime they need something like Ben has
to go over and do it and it's really
like a generational thing I mean and and
I think it has a lot to do with those
classes a hundred percent like we were
taking computer science classes but
right signs right right and like you go
today we're taking the whole Mack I
don't know how to so do you I know I do
not that's true also an important skill
my yeah we get take both yeah because
now when I watch friends they talk a lot
about home AK like the home ed class had
to make a mascot costume for Monica
because she was too big for like they
seek woodshop yeah like those were the
the trades of the the time period yeah
but I do wish I had taken a home that
class I feel like I could have learned a
thing or two about being a homemaker
know about sewing seems to me important
is home X stand for Oh magic ation
economics I don't know interesting
someone will let us know yes home
eccentricity yeah uh this is an
interesting study because it's now
making me feel like soon you know if you
are able to answer quicker on your phone
like why would you go to your computer
except I'm actually incapable of
answering anything on my phone I know
it's a terrible trait that you have it
is but I leave everything unread until I
get to my computer the probably see
something like so pressingly but will
you were you running it will you run
home and do it on your computer and I
would I would answer in that moment but
you know what I do sometimes it's like
so bad is I I'll get like an email that
I won the lottery just like send back
the letter Q to receive and I'll be so
excited a screenshot I'll send it to
everyone right and then I forget that I
have to respond yeah you know oh also I
want to give a personal update because
yesterday was Yom Kippur me couldn't do
anything I didn't do all and now I'm on
day two of node rolling like I'm done
with it you are yeah I wanted to give a
personal update because this weekend I
actually did Jul because I went out but
I wasn't drinking so I was like what am
I gonna do with myself right um but then
I didn't jewel again and this is like a
really pivotal time for the jewel
community you know I know I kind of just
waited and there was another report
there isn't like an official report that
says Julian's where I came out know
their this week that was like the mice
were vaping got lung cancer oh and that
was like the first time that beeping has
been to related to lung cancer but also
look we're not mice no I know um I'm
just gonna like wait this one out and
see see where the research side I'm
gonna keep following up with it I'm
gonna stop drilling as much as I was
doing because I wanted to do that anyway
and like if we want to have like baby
suno right
we can't be Julie can't be also home
actor Sam for Home Economics and I I'm
I'm feeling good I'm 24 hours no jewel
it's so crazy cuz like I feel like I got
hooked on my jewel so quickly like a
couple months ago I actually remember
where I got hooked on my jewel
I could probably trace it back cam toast
and you want to know why cuz like we
were with our friend who drools all the
time and like she was Julie in the bunk
and I'm like oh I guess I could you all
right no no it's sad well in coffee does
sound good yeah and then once you
realize that it's like there's nowhere
you can't jewel yeah and I've just been
Julianne like way too much like I used
to really like party jewel and I didn't
think there was anything wrong with that
like there's worse things I could be
doing at a party than ripping a jewel
and then it just like took over my life
and like I was honestly thinking about
the jewel all the time and like honestly
I'm definitely teaching for it right now
like just talking about it but I think I
need to get like a full week clean and
then I'll be over it completely because
you said not think about it at all now
we think about it all the time yeah it's
it's really true cam toast message we'll
have the environment but also like my
whole thing like I think I'm never
outside and so when I'm outside I want
to breathe in the air like I want a
[ __ ] rip a jewel but camtonz we were
outside the whole time so like that
right ripping the jewel the whole time
oh so people have been asking I've been
getting a bunch of questions that I Kim
chose tickets when are they gonna become
available holiday see how load a season
it's gonna be the same time as last year
because if you want to get it for
someone as a gift for Christmas Hanukkah
Kwanzaa also it is the same weekend I've
got I've been getting a bunch of
questions Maury on a memorial to me in
2020 I'm spending or more than a weekend
with us now but you have the Monday off
you don't have to miss anything and you
know what like Memorial Day weekend like
is so overrated I find like a musty of a
wedding Jackie the weather actually like
in New York it's not always like good
enough for you to like go to the
swimming yeah um and it's just like a
beautiful weekend in the Poconos
hey great I want to jinx it but like
it's like cool enough that we've now
done wedding to camp toasts one where it
was terrible weather arraigned every
single day and one where was so
beautiful wasn't even that hot but like
the Sun came out we got to spin but we
were also not that hot at night like we
got to wear sweat pants and they were
both great honestly Hamish I'd camp
toast is [ __ ] legit yeah yeah rain
was cool too it's gonna be great I can't
leave we're not going on our third one I
know and be some really good things
planned we did we actually need to like
set a meeting - yeah just hunker down
just been so busy uh merch is coming
back soon so ever it's already been a
week since we launched it on Friday
right and we I thought today was
Monday's Thursday and we we reordered on
Friday right yes so it'll be a little
over a week next week we'll give you
guys the day welcome you a set time by
the way I know everyone was really
annoyed but I have to let you know what
we ordered so many quantities like we
really had no idea that it was gonna
sell so well and this is obviously a
good problem to have but I feel that you
guys are annoyed to be totally
understanding this time we ordered so
many [ __ ] quantities that if they
don't sell out we are gonna be literally
broke so just trust me we are learning
and for everyone I understand that like
people are annoyed that they couldn't
get and they said we would have rather
waited three weeks but that's not the
case because people who ordered on
Friday got their merch like a couple
days ago like the the time now is so
quick that by the time you get from the
restock it's still shorter than in the
last times yeah right we're ordering so
many [ __ ] teal sweatshirts like yeah
we'll be wearing teal sweatshirts for
the rest of our lives totally bury me in
this heel sweatshirt totally I [ __ ]
love that spot geo I wore it all weekend
it got me recognized by Jim Gaffigan I'm
literally gonna wear it like all through
LA yep there's I love wearing toe smart
Michio honestly it makes for just like
easy wardrobe choices they are like cute
clean e-content wear a bar and it's also
just like a little
the only negative it said it's a big
sweater to pack but I'm checking a bag
for LA week I don't too much you you I'm
bringing like so many shoe shopping I
was actually I'm gonna go shopping today
and I was gonna ask if anyone wanted to
come well I just gotta go to my eyebrows
done and then okay that's cool we'll
meet up late where should we go um where
do people shop I don't know they like go
shop and then this happens to me like
every six months I'm like you know what
I need new jeans I'm gonna go like try
some on right a denim bar oh no and I
just like have a mental breakdown I
don't know who those denim bars are made
for cuz it's like certainly not me or
anyone I know like I've never I just I
wish I honestly I hope that could be the
type of person I wanna take like walks
into a denim bar and like finds pair
jeans no find success right in a denim
bar but I just like don't have enough
pants like because I have like I
literally went to wear pants today and I
didn't have what I need it like no and
this fall you need some pants
yeah we're falling into fall here thank
you guys so much for listening to
morning trust I wanted to remind you
that I'm hitting up la San Diego San
Francisco this weekend and next weekend
for my shows the dirty jeans tour
tickets are available girl no job calm
San Francisco is pretty much sold out I
second show I think there might be
tickets left to the earlier show San
Diego NL I have a few tickets left so
head over to girl job comm Jackie's
gonna be there it's gonna be so great
Margo's gonna be there it's gonna be
family standing up there this has been
an absolute pleasure thank you for
spending your mornings with us we really
appreciate it by the way morning show
Selena Morning Show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching us
on YouTube please subscribe thumbs up
comment the whole shebang we're also
available as a podcast but you probably
know if you're listening to us as a
podcast right now we're available on
Spotify on iTunes on stitcher on public
radio iHeartRadio Cass box pretty much
anywhere you can listen to podcast so
subscribe over there leave a five star
review about how beautiful setting and
smart we are and how you agree with
absolutely everything that we say we
love you guys so much have an amazing
Thursday we'll see you tomorrow for
Friday Friday gotta get down on Friday
you